Ich, ja. Guten Abend. Guten Abend. Ich heiße Mohammed Hamid. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Assistent, als Statist und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Ja. Zuerst bitte ich stelle ich ein paar
allgemeine Fragen und dann kommen wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden. Ist
es Ihnen in Ordnung? Ist in Ordnung, ja. Danke. Wie heißen Sie denn? Ich heiße Volker
Gottschalk. Volko Gottschalk? Gottschalk. Konntest du bitte langsam
noch stabilieren? Ja, der Vorname Volker mit F-O-L-K-E-R Volker und der
Vorname Gottschalk G-O-T-T-S-C-H-A-L-K Gottschalk. Gottschalk.
Gottschalk. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 38. Und wann sind Sie genau gebraucht?
Am 12. Mai 1984. Und wie groß sind Sie bitte? Ich bin 1,82 m. Und wie viel wiegen Sie? 78 Kilo.
Gottschalk. Was fuhren Sie zu uns? Ja, ich habe jetzt schon seit einigen Wochen
habe ich jetzt schon viel Durchfall und auch teilweise Bauchschmerzen. Und es ist in den
letzten Tagen noch schlimmer geworden. In den letzten Wochen ist es noch mehr
geworden. Und das macht mir jetzt Sorgen und ich fühle mich auch nicht wohl.
Seit einer Woche ist es schlimmer geworden und die Durchfälle und die Bauchschmerzen habe ich jetzt aber
schon mindestens seit sechs Wochen. Konntet ihr uns bitte mehr über die Bauchschmerzen beschreiben?
Zum Beispiel sind die Schmerzen genau? Wie sind die Schmerzen? Sie erraten mehr so in Höhe des Bauchnabels,
aber ein bisschen mehr links, aber auch fast im ganzen Bauch, aber mehr so auf der linken Seite.
Und die sind meistens ist das so eher so ein dumfer Schmerz, aber manchmal ist es auch ja wie so eine Welle.
Und sind die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich angefangen?
Die sind langsam angefangen. Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser vor diesen Schmerzen? Nein, habe ich bisher nicht beobachtet.
Gibt es etwas, die Schmerzen vermindernt oder verstärkt? Ich habe mal eine Wärmflasche probiert.
Das war glaube ich nicht ganz so gut. Also das war danach etwas schlechter.
Haben Sie Medikamente gegen diese Schmerzen eingenommen? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Hören Sie bei anderen Arztwaren oder Besuchten? Nein, bis jetzt noch nicht.
Ich wollte eigentlich jetzt nächste Woche zu meinem Hausarzt gehen, aber da ist es jetzt schlimmer geworden ist
und schlechter, dachte ich, ich gehe jetzt erstmal, komme ich in die Klinik.
Okay, und Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen manchmal dumpf, manchmal wellartig.
Aber meistens sind Sie dumpf?
Sind Sie dauerhaft oder manchmal weg?
Ja, es gibt manchmal Zeiten, wo die Schmerzen eher nicht so sind, aber ganz weg sind Sie nicht.
Auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei ein sehr leichten Schmerz und sehr stärkeren Schmerzen entspricht, wie ist Ihre Schmerzintensität?
Ich würde sagen 4.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir vor durchfärmen. Wie viel Mal haben Sie pro Tag?
Ach so, 4 bis 6 Mal.
Und gibt es Blut im Sturzgang oder keine Blut?
Ja, manchmal ist da auch etwas Blut dabei und es ist viel Schleim und Blut.
Und gibt es Veränderungen in der Farbe, zum Beispiel dunkel oder hell?
Der Sturzgang ist meist eher ein bisschen dunkel.
Und fuhlen Sie besser nach dem Sturzgang?
Nein, nicht unbedingt.
Haben Sie Oberkeit oder Erbrischen?
Nein, direkt nicht. Erbrechen nicht, Oberkeit nicht, aber ich habe nicht mehr so gut Appetit.
Ich fühle mich eher auch ein bisschen schlapp.
Ist Ihnen ein Schwimmbelis? Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber? Ja.
Ich habe etwas Temperatur hin und wieder jetzt gemessen. Das ist so zwischen 37,5 und 38,5.
Normalerweise ist das niedriger bei mir.
Ich habe nicht mehr gehört, wo sind Sie gemessen?
Im Mund habe ich gemessen.
Wann war das letzte Mal?
Gestern Abend.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder Galzschweiß?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Schlafstörung oder Schlafstörung?
Schlafstörung, ich wache manchmal auf.
In der Nacht muss ich auch auf Toilette wegen Stuhlgang.
Manchmal auch wegen der Bauchmerzen kann ich nicht so gut schlafen.
Haben Sie gemerkt, in letzter Zeit Ihre Gewicht verändert?
Gewichtsabnahme?
Ja, innerhalb der letzten 4 Wochen habe ich fast 3 kg Gewicht verloren.
Haben Sie Probleme?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Mein Puls geht vielleicht etwas schneller, aber Herzrasen habe ich nicht.
Herr Gottschalk, haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe mich immer ganz wohl gefühlt.
Aber die letzten 6 Wochen mit dem Durchfall ging es immer gut.
Ich konnte auch Sport machen, da habe ich nicht mehr so große Lust zu.
Ich habe gefragt, ob etwas verschlimmert oder vermindert ist.
Ich habe gesagt, als ich mit der Wärmflasche auf dem Bauch, wurde es etwas schlechter.
Aber ich meine Essen oder?
Nein, da sehe ich keinen Unterschied.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, als Kind zweimal am Blinddamm und einmal am Leistenbruch.
Was war das?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Im Blinddamm war vielleicht mit 8 Jahren und im Leistenbruch mit 11.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Nein, ich nehme keine regelmäßigen Medikamente.
Sind Sie vollständig geirrt?
Ja, ich habe die normalen Impfungen.
Und gegen Corona?
Ja, dreimal.
Bleiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich spiele zweimal in der Woche Tischtennis.
Waren Sie im letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich war vor zwei Jahren in Italien für eine Woche.
Aber das ist schon zwei Jahre her.
Sonst war ich nicht im Ausland.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Herr Gottschalk,
bleiben Ihre Eltern an chronischer Erkrankung?
Mein Vater ist 68, der hatte einen Herzinfarkt vor zehn Jahren.
Aber das hat er gut überstanden.
Er hat auch einen hohen Blutdruck und hat auch erhöhtes Cholesterin.
Da nimmt er Medikamente gegen und sagt, er ist jetzt damit ganz gut eingestellt.
Mehr weiß ich nicht.
Mein Mutter ist 67 Jahre alt,
hat eine Arthrose in der Hüfte und einen Alterszucker.
Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist 40 Jahre alt, der hat Asthma.
Welche Mutter hat Zücherkrankheit?
Wissen Sie, welche?
Man sagt, es wäre Alterszucker.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Gottschalk?
Ja, ohne meiner Frau zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter, die ist zwölf Jahre alt und ist gesund.
Leben Sie alle zusammen?
Ja.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Lehrer.
Haben Sie einen Stress bei Arbeit?
Ja, zurzeit ist die Arbeit sehr anstrengend.
Herr Gottschalk, gerauchen Sie?
Ich habe geraucht bis vor fünf Jahren.
Da habe ich 15 Jahre, circa 15 Jahre,
habe ich geraucht, 20 Zigaretten am Tag.
Und vor fünf Jahren habe ich aufgehört.
Vor fünf Jahren haben Sie aufgehört.
Ich habe gut gehört, wie lange Zeit haben Sie aufgehört?
15 Jahre habe ich geraucht und ungefähr eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke Bier.
Aber keinen Schnaps oder keinen Wein.
Ich trinke Bier, aber so circa in der Woche,
so drei Flaschen, aber mehr nicht.
Drei Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Herr Gottschalk, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Brocken?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe die wichtige Frage gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich oder mussten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe noch beobachtet, in den letzten Tagen habe ich häufiger
auch so Gelenkschmerzen im Knie, im linken Knie und im Fuß,
im Sprunggelenk.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen dicker geworden.
Dann sagt meine Frau, ist mein linkes Auge gerötet.
Und da muss ich nächste Woche zum Augenarzt.
Ja, gneckeleng und Fußgelenk, ja?
Ja, links, linkes, gneckeleng und linkes Fuß,
unten Sprunggelenk.
Und auch das linke Auge, das ist gerötet und irgendwie so empfindlich.
Ich habe schon einen Termin beim Augenarzt,
jetzt in drei Tagen, soll ich da hinkommen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay, ja.
Okay, haben Sie eine Frage an mich?
Ja, was habe ich?
Naja, bestimmte Diagnose, ich kann nicht sagen,
ich kann nicht jetzt sagen, wir brauchen noch andere
Untersuchungen und korbische Untersuchungen.
Und danach, wir können eine bestimmte Diagnose stellen.
Wir können sagen, dass Sie eine enthologische Krankheit haben,
wahrscheinlich so genannt Morbus-Kron,
oder Colon-Enzündung.
Ja, aber das ist eine verdachte Diagnose,
bestimmte Diagnose.
Nach dem korbischen Untersuchung und weiteren Untersuchungen,
wir können darüber noch einmal reden.
Okay, gut, dann machen wir es.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen eine andere Frage?
Also ich denke, die Allergen und Vorerkrankungen fehlen noch,
oder? Haben Sie schon gestern?
Vorerkrankungen, ich habe gefragt, ja, aber Allergien ja nicht.
Allergien habe ich nicht, keine Allergien.
Ein paar Fragen, sind dich mehr,
stellen dich mehr in eine bestimmte Region auf?
Nein, die sind mehr so immer im Bauch.
Und ich habe schon gesagt, mehr so auf der linken Seite im Bauch.
Vorher haben Sie die Duft-Fall-Und-Boxen?
Ob ich ähnliche Beschwerden habe?
Ja, ähnliche Beschwerden haben Sie.
Ob ich die schon mal gehabt habe?
Nein, vor ein Jahr, vor fünf Jahren.
Das Ganze ist so seit sechs Wochen.
Da hat das angefangen, vor sechs Wochen.
Vorher hatte ich das nicht.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ich habe Mundhöhle, etwas Änderungen?
Mundhöhle, nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haft zum Beispiel, oder?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ich habe Haut, etwas Veränderungen?
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Ich habe das nicht aufgefallen.
Auch ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie bemerkt, in der Haut Veränderungen?
Ich habe bemerkt.
Ja, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Wie viel am Tag müssen Sie für Duft-Fall-Und-Boxen gehen?
Der Kollege hatte schon befragt,
ich so vier bis sechs Mal im Schnitt.
Es war auch schon mal mehr, aber meistens so vier bis sechs Mal.
Können wir als Tagsgespräch anfangen?
Bitte Ihnen nur zwei, drei Minuten,
ich möchte medizinische Begriffe schleigen.
Alles klar.
Dann hole ich mir noch einen Tee.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberl-Arts.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne die neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit vor mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Danke.
Er heißt Volka Gottschalk.
Er ist 38 Jahre alt und zwar geboren am 12. Mai 1984.
Er ist 1 Meter, 82 kg groß und wiegt 78 kg.
Der Patient hat bei uns heute wegen, seit ungefähr 6 Wochen,
Diarrheum und Bauchschmerzen vorgestellt.
Der Patient berichtete, dass die Schmerzen in den ganzen Bauch
und insbesondere in der Linke unter dem Bauch besteht.
Außerdem klagte er, dass die Schmerzen dumpf und wellartige sind.
Ja, die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten, ohne bestimmte Ausloser.
Die Schmerzintensität entspricht 4 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Bei Wörnflächen sind die Schmerzen stärker geworden.
Wobei sind die Schmerzen stärker geworden?
Wörnflächen.
Wärme-Expositionen oder Wärme wurden nicht gut toleriert.
Die Schmerzen haben keine Ausstrahlung.
Wir sind die Schmerzen stärker geworden.
Welche Ausstrahlung sind die Durchfälle?
Kann der Patient die Durchfälle beschreiben?
Ja, okay.
Die Diare hat der Patient seit sechster Wochen.
Er hat vier bis sechsmal täglich mit Blut und Schlein.
Die Farbe ist ein bisschen dunkel,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob man das sagen kann.
Die Frage nach Nausea und Hermesis wurden verneint.
Die Divertative an Hermesis ergab in Sonne.
Der Patient war bis auf in Sonne.
Der Patient war bis auf die Temperatur gemessen.
Der Patient berichtet teilweise über febrile Temperaturen bis 38,5 per Os gemessen.
Der Patient war gestern gemessen.
Was macht das Gewicht?
Der Patient berüchtete, dass er ungefähr 3 Kilogramm in Zeitraum vier Wochen abgenommen.
Gibt es andere klinische Erscheinungen beim Patienten?
Ja, ich lasse die Sturrungen wegen Diavor.
Die Frage nach Atemnode, Husten, wurde verneint.
Aber er hat ein bisschen Halsmuss schneller.
Hat der Patient sonst noch Beschwerden im Bereich der Extremitäten?
Ja, ich komme zu orthopedischen Verteleuten.
Der Patient gab an, dass er in den letzten Wochen Atralgie in linken Knie und den linken Bus gelenkt.
Er klagte auch über Konjunktivitis.
Ein oftalbologischer Termin steht noch aus.
Das kann sein, aber auch keine Konjunktivitis.
Die Frage nach Vorerkrankungen wurde für nein.
Beim Patienten wurde eine Abendektomie mit 8 Jahre alt durchgeführt.
Eine Ergänzung von 11 Jahren.
Die Ergänzung und die Unverträglichkeit sind nicht bekannt.
Der Patient nimmt keine regelmäßig Medikamente.
Der Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Er ist 3-mal gegen COVID-19 geimpft.
Er treibt regelmäßig Sport.
Der Patient braucht nicht Zeit.
Vor 15 Jahren hat er ca. eine Einpackung täglich.
Der Patient hat bis vor 5 Jahren einen Nikotin-Abusus über 15 Packages gehabt.
Er bringt maximal 3 Flasche Bier pro Woche.
Die Frage nach Drogenkonsum wurde für nein.
Die Familie Anemnese gab einen Herz bei dem Vater.
Ich habe die wesentlichen Dinge geschildert.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ich habe eine Verdachtdiagnose Morbus Crohn.
Wie ist die Erkrankung?
Es gibt eine Menge Anerkrankungen.
Wie ist die Diagnose?
Ich habe eine Mikrobiologische Diagnose.
Das wäre im Rahmen einer endoscopischen Untersuchung.
Ich habe eine Verkaufung von der Diagnose.
Ich empfehle die Systematik.
Das wäre in einem Fachgespräch der inneren Medizin.
Ich habe eine Verkaufung von der Diagnose.
Heute stellt sich heute in der Notaufnahme mit seit sechs Wochen bestehenden Durchfällen und Bauchschmerzen vor.
Nicht noch längere Sätze machen, weil das ist lieber kurz und knapp.
Und dann kommt der nächste Satz.
Sonst können Sie Probleme kriegen mit der Formulierung oder mit der Grammatik.
Das ist einfach ein Ratschlach.
Ich habe mich auf achten Liebe einen kurzen Satz machen.
Der Patient stellt sich mit Diarrö und rezidivierenden Bauchschmerzen vor.
Diese Beschwerden haben sich in den letzten sieben Tagen akzentuiert.
Das glaube ich für Sie einfacher oder risikulös.